I don't know about you but to me nothing
screams holiday season like seeing a
couple of miserably married people this
is 40 so this is for T is another judd
apatow comedy I'd call it more of a
drama D his Paul Rudd and the chick who
plays his wife whose name I can't even
remember right now and they're married
and they're 40 and now this is life I
really don't need to give much more of a
description than that because that's
what the movie is about it's about a
couple of people who just turned 40 and
it's their life their marriage their
life with their kids their jobs their
money their financial situations all the
things that make married couples fight
and be miserable we get to see in this
movie no surprise to my subscribers I
usually knock marriage and I give
marriage a hard time I should say go
watch this is 40 because this is 40 will
show you exactly why it is a very
realistic take on marriage you know
these two people are married and they
just they fight they don't look happy I
get what he's trying to do and I respect
what he's trying to do I personally
think that Judd Apatow is trying to win
an Oscar or at least to make a comedy
that's more than just a comedy he wants
to make them you know sections of life
itself but and this is 40 he might have
gone a little too far bummer is when
you're dealing with a married couple
sometimes it's just uncomfortable to
watch something that rail now Paul Rudd
and the chick who plays his wife whose
name I can't remember at all they do a
really good job they have good chemistry
as a married couple you know there's
some times with her small talking you
know like you saw in the trailer and
she's like oh how would you kill me if
you could kill me Paul Rudd's like oh
I'd kill you this way and then she's
like oh I'd kill you this way it was it
was cool it was cool to see married
couples should talk about how they would
kill each other because they all think
about it communication trust key in any
relationship I learned that from done
with the dead but then they're screaming
at each other and they're pissed at each
other and they hate each other and
you're just like this is way too real
too uncomfortable to watch alright it
was kind of cute before when you were
talking about killing each other ever
been to your friend's house and he and
his wife are arguing or fighting and
you're like it's just uncomfortable in
the air right now it's like that but you
can't leave it's you're there you're
stuck with it the movie had funny parts
my favorite part was Melissa McCarthy
she's not in the movie much but when she
is she's just going off and you're like
are you ad libbing right now funniest
part and the entire movie is the end
credits scene and it just shows Melissa
McCarthy ad-libbing funny thing is most
of what she said they actually used in
the movie but you see Paul Rudd
and the chick who plays his wife who
again I can't remember her name
it shows how they're reacting and
they're just dying they're laughing
their asses off which makes you laugh
your ass off that perpetual cycle of
comedy and laughter and you just you're
laughing you're having a good time
you're like cool that happened I'm glad
this movie gave me that in the end
credits this is what I think is
happening with Judd Apatow movies at a
point he was like I'm gonna make a
comedy and put a little bit of heart in
it it's gonna work it's gonna be great
in the next movie I'm gonna put a little
bit more drama in it and the next one a
little more and I was like a painter who
starts out with some abstract splats and
then he just starts losing his mind and
going nuts and splattering the canvas
that is what Judd Apatow is doing with
his movies with drama a lot more drama
than comedy and you don't really know
what the point of the movie is there's
no thing that's like okay this is the
point and we're going to reach that
point it's gonna be resolved however of
the people who do their job well in the
movie there is one I have to commend
that is Megan Fox she's in this movie to
contribute nothing other than to have
someone to look at oh yeah she's totally
hot she's way hot I hate the fact that I
think she's hot my higher brain function
is like dude don't be stupid my genetics
are like up yep totally hot she's not
talented she was fired by Michael Bay
Michael Bay said no you're not good
enough to be in my [ __ ] think about that
of all the collaborations that have gone
on in the world you got to admit a
pretty good collaboration that did
happen in our lifetime was God making
Megan Fox and dr. 9:02 enoguh alt week
her event you're going you to you not
bad in the end this is 40 has good
actors doing their part with the content
they have good timing but the movies too
long it doesn't really have a point it's
just uncomfortable in parts I will say
this is 40 is a good time if you're
drunk
yeah no it's a and remember there are
two kinds of guys in life guys who would
totally have crazy animalistic sex with
Megan Fox and guys who totally would
have crazy animalistic sex with Megan
Fox but won't admit it because their
girlfriends or wives are in the room and
if you comment below now it is she's
totally that's just because your
girlfriend or wife has access to your
YouTube account so you need to comment
like that to make her think that you
actually believe it but you don't so for
you what is the most uncomfortable
dramedy you know those comedies that are
dramas and you have the couple that
fights and you're like that's just not
fun to sit through whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]